hello everybody I'm prestige if you're
watching this that means you are new to
my channel let me introduce it this is a
gay me check about Minecraft I'll call
duty of some other game I like playing
these video games sure all of you do
some of them at least I like posting I
like recorded myself playing the game
like posting it to YouTube stuff all you
guys to talk about it share it with
friends talk to me that back about
coming which I like what you didn't like
and if you're into that kind of stuff
you're asking channel then I suggest
hopping on click Subscribe clicking like
talking to me in the comments that I
will respond because I just enjoy more
feedback and this is a channel that I
want to base around you guys but if you
guys like I'm gonna be posted so if you
guys don't like something I won't post
it if you like something a little post
as long as I have fun I want me myself
to have fun I want you guys to have fun
I want it to be a fun experience perfect
so if you think you're gonna like my
channel or you like this video make sure
you hit the subscribe button on screen
around a little subscribe around my
emblem or the subscribe button below
which is right next to my name you'll
see it don't work so hope you guys can
hop onto the experience and I'll see you
later